where does this hatred from to to
Christians and Christianity just come
out of nowhere from what what did we do
so wrong to make like that Muslim
Community just hate and want to kill us
right off the r right off the ri look
there are 2,000 years of war history in
the Middle East this did not start
yesterday yeah but it ramped up after um
the creation of the religion of Islam
now not all Muslims are radical you and
I we we lived in the Middle East Patrick
they are the most wonderful people
hospitable kind openhearted not all of
them want to kill you however there is
such a radical element to the religion
if you are a Christian or a Jew or
Armenian raised in the Middle East you
understand there's a
saying first comes Saturday then comes
Sunday first we kill the Jews then we
come for the Christians so if you're a
child raised in the Middle East you're
raised hearing this sentence